We covered a number of topics so far.
But you'll see that all of
them have focused on problems
that we address in the context
of a single computer.
Unfortunately, a single computer
is not very interesting by itself.
It has to be connected to a network.
And when we connect
computer to our networks,
that brings in a whole bunch
of new security problems.
That's where we're going to go on
to the second part of the course.
We have a world-class
network security researcher
who's actually going to take you there.
>> For part of this course,
we're going to cover a number of
major topics in network security.
We're going to start off with
malware and network defenses.
Then we're going to move on topography,
security protocols, web security and
mobile security.